[Music]
slark an API developer has been working
on a micro service app for a major
clothing retailer that sends customers
coupons to nearby outlets he checks in
his code and gets an error message
rejected you need to have security and
traffic management capabilities because
this is a secure service markets worried
knowing he has little time left to meet
his deadline he takes a break starts
looking through his email when he sees
an article from his favorite tech blog
IBM DataPower gateway saves a startup
the story talks about a small firm
implementing data power as its gateway
solution and received a massive traffic
influx with no connection errors or
slowdown data powers robust architecture
and powerful toolset enable the firm to
respond to high customer interests
optimize traditional revenue channels
and create new channels mark meets his
colleague Jane and IT architect to learn
how data power can help solve his
problem he learned how data power can
quickly help them set up gateway
services to secure and optimize access
to the backend acting as a single hub
and apply configured policies to all
traffic without wasting any further time
Marc uses the data power gateway to
connect his mobile application to the
micro service in a few minutes
securing your API traffic is as simple
as starting a docker container and
opening your browser define your
front-end and back-end parameters and
that's all it takes to build and secure
the digital channels that you need to
succeed with data power on doctrines his
code is finally accepted and now it's
time for deployment to production Tony a
DevOps engineer deploys the code he
realizes he needs more space as he
starts stacking physical data power but
the stack gets too high enter the cloud
and a green deploy button giving a
perfect stack of data power in the cloud
the app is launched
the Gateway is performing and the
developers are seeing revenue generated
from their api's and real-time on the
dashboard data power also acts as a
shock absorber gracefully handling new
requests saving the backend from being
overwhelmed mark is happy confident that
his gateways will keep operating and his
api's will keep making him money data
power gateways are specialized
consumable purpose-built gateways to
secure managed control and optimize your
growing edge of the network requirements
whether you're protecting and optimizing
api's mobile applications b2b cloud or
web services data power is there to help
try data power on dr to see it yourself
[Music]